yeah i remember when i was a kid we used
to go to the movies a lot
and uh my my parents were immigrants to
england
and so going to the movies for them was
uh
they they loved it when like italian or
spanish movies were being shown and
we used to go at least once a week
sometimes more
and so we got into the habit of seeing
movies and i remember the
one of the most i think probably the
most influential film that on me when i
was a kid
um certainly was when i saw spartacus
with uh kirk douglas and
i'm not quite sure why i don't quite
know why that was so
influential but i do remember thinking
that
in some way that that's what i wanted to
do
uh not be not be a gladiator exactly but
but want to to be a an actor
and and i but i didn't really know what
it meant i didn't really know what
being a film actor entailed at that
point but i just knew
that and i think maybe it was something
to do with
how real it seemed in some way how
how uh it wasn't like a fantasy somehow
that these were real
men and women it's it must have kind of
got to me on some level like that but in
a very unsophisticated way but it had a
huge influence on me and it stayed
and it was it was the film that whenever
i got a chance to see it again i would
always watch it i still do i still
you know when uh when it gets shown on
tv
or you know i i always watch it and
i sort of uh or or if it's on i'll just
you know
turn it on and just catch it like
halfway through or something it's and
it's
incredibly watchful and terribly i find
it i still find it incredibly moving you
know
when they all stand up you know i'm
spotted because i'm you it's become a
joke now but i i still
i still i still get you know so we're
very excited about it
when uh when i see that movie so that
was i suppose that one and
another film that that was very
influential and
but in a more in a more sophisticated
way i think was
uh was when i was a bit older and um and
i remember seeing
um some some sort of rather harder edged
british movies that were coming out in
the late 60s
and you know darling and um
you know uh dirk bogart's movies there
was something really
you know the servant all those films
but that was to do with a style that
completely caught my imagination and and
i remember being very aware that dirk
bogart
for instance always struck me as being
the quintessential film actor
um i never saw him perform on stage and
i don't think he performed on stage at
all very often
but on film he was he seemed like
quintessentially
um what film acting how what it could be
you know and and as as i got older i
thought that the list of people who were
inspiring me got bigger and bigger but
those are the two moments i think when i
was really aware of something
something happening that was kind of
specific